Have you ever had an imaginary friend?
Maybe you did when you were very little and
then forgot all about it.
That first friend you ever had, the one you
told all your secrets, your fears, the one
you trusted and listened to for advice when
you weren’t sure if something was right
or wrong.
The one you swore you would carry with you
everywhere you went, that sacred pact that
slowly drifted into nothingness.
And then you forgot.
Well, what if those imaginary friends weren’t
imaginary after all.
Just what were they?
Where did they come from?
And are they still out there somewhere, waiting
for us to think them back into existence?
Today’s story begins not in our childhood,
but deep inside a hidden underground facility
where a man sits in his enclosed habitat protected
by round-the-clock armed SCP Foundation security
personnel.
This man is a middle-aged normal human being
without any unique physical characteristics.
He is not a member of the O5 council, nor
is he a foreign dignitary or a person in any
position of political power.
And yet, the safety and protection of this
man’s life are of paramount importance.
And what threatens that safety is the subject
of today’s video.
The entity that hunts him, SCP-1447, also
known as The Tulpa.
SCP-1447-1 is the Foundation’s designation
for the floating quasi-physical humanoid entity
that resembles the appearance of a traditional
Buddhist monk, but whose face appears perpetually
distorted.
The word “Tulpa” is a Tibetan word that
means “emanation” or “magical creation”.
The idea being that a practitioner of deep
meditation could focus hard enough to conjure
a physical manifestation of a thought or an
idea.
SCP-1447-1 is a Keter class entity currently
being held in an airtight 2.5x 2.5x 2.5 concrete
container suspended above the ground in Bay
4.
The cell is to be repeatedly reinforced with
steel plating, with regular inspections for
any damage to the containment structure.
Any cracks or breaks in SCP-1447-1’s containment
are to be reported immediately and considered
a breach-level event.
This is due to SCP-1447-1’s ability to insert
itself into breaches and cracks as small as
200 micrometers in diameter.
Meaning that even the smallest crack in its
containment enclosure will almost certainly
lead to SCP-1447-1’s escape.
While the tulpa seems uninterested in killing
anyone other than the facility’s previously
mentioned resident, it will not hesitate in
killing any personnel that prevents it from
achieving its principal goal.
SCP-1447-1 appears unaffected by small arms
fire from standard-issue Foundation sidearms,
seemingly impervious to any physical means
of damage.
However, suppressive fire from high caliber
weaponry does seem to have an effect on SCP-1447-1,
appearing to temporarily disrupt the projection
of its physical form.
This concentration of high-caliber fire has
proven to be effective in forcing SCP-1447-1
back into its containment enclosure.
Explosives also seem to have the positive
effect of completely dissipating SCP-1447’s
physical presence, however, this has the undesired
side effect of the entity then re-materializing
somewhere else in the immediate vicinity.
This rematerialization is not impeded by physical
structures, sometimes allowing the tulpa to
bypass defensive positions and obstacles entirely.
Although SCP-1447-1 appears on security footage
to hover slowly toward its intended target,
SCP-1447’s behavior in containment is quite
the opposite.
For 20 hours of the day, the tulpa moves around
its containment cell at a staggering 200km
per hour, punching dents into its enclosure
hoping to create a weakness in the structure
that it can exploit.
It requires no rest and appears to have limitless
stamina.
Despite researchers’ best efforts to film
SCP-1447-1 using a high-speed camera, its
face is still impossible to see as it remains
in perpetual motion and only visible as a
blur to the human eye.
Attempts at communication with SCP-1447-1
have been inconclusive.
When asked a question the tulpa will respond
with unintelligible garbled responses that,
when slowed down, appear to be traditional
Tibetan mantras repeated hundreds of times
a second.
SCP-1447-1 does seem to exhibit signs of intelligence
and even deceit, as on one occasion it was
observed goading security personnel into attacking
it with explosive devices as it was near the
entrance of another SCP’s enclosure, leading
to a double breach event.
SCP-1447-2 is the designation given to the
man currently confined to his quarters inside
the containment site.
He is a software and hardware engineer and
entrepreneur whose name has been redacted
from official records.
We will refer to him from here on simply as
“Steve”.
The following is information the subject gave
SCP Foundation staff willingly.
Steve was an accomplished man, excelling at
everything he did and finding a great level
of success in the tech sector as a developer
and entrepreneur.
And yet, with all the riches and fame that
his success brought him, he found himself
wanting more.
His obsessiveness for a sense of meaningful
fulfillment led him to drive away loved ones
and dive further into his work, creating a
vicious cycle of self-isolation leaving him
with a greater sense of unfulfillment from
his life.
One day, Steve came to the realization that
what he needed was to split away from the
reality he had created for himself.
He needed to find peace, and he knew he couldn’t
do it where he currently was.
He packed a bag and, without a second thought,
decided to leave everything behind without
saying a word to anyone about where he was
going.
But where was he going? he had thought to
himself.
Following a trend of westerners traveling
to Asia to find a new sense of enlightenment,
Steve boarded a plane to Qinghai Province,
China, where he joined an order of monastic
monks.
As he did with most aspects of his life, he
threw himself entirely into the practice,
dressing like the brothers of the order in
the traditional monastic garb and even electing
to shave his head bare, switching to a vegetarian
diet, and learning the Tibetan mantras.
He put his sole effort into learning the art
of deep meditation, vowing to truly split
away from the repetitive unfulfilling life
he had chosen to leave behind.
During one particular lesson, Steve learned
from an elder brother at the monastery about
the concept of a “tulpa”, a method where
a person enters deep focused meditation to
conjure a physical visual manifestation of
a specific thought or emotion.
Being new to the practice at the time, Steve
couldn’t find himself thinking of anything
but the image of a laughing buddha he was
used to seeing every time he entered a local
Chinese restaurant back in the United States.
He remembered how the image made him feel
welcome, how the look of joy on the Buddha's
face brought a look of joy to his own.
Explaining this to the brothers at the monastery,
they promptly corrected him that this image
is not an image of the buddha, as in the sense
of the buddha being a single defined deity,
but just one of many interpretations of buddha.
The laughing buddha is particularly a cultural
symbol of luck and abundance.
The monks asked Steve to picture something
else when attempting to visualize a tulpa,
such as an emotion that has taken form and
shape.
But try as he could, Steve had become fixated
on the image of the popular laughing buddha,
and could do little to imagine anything else.
On his own, Steve meditated persistently in
this endeavor, truly expecting success and
working towards it with the fervent drive
he put into every project in his life.
And to the amazement of himself and the brothers
of the monastery, his tulpa slowly began to
manifest.
It was small at first, only an image that
he could see.
He didn't think much of it, not thinking that
he had created anything real.
He believed the image of the laughing buddha
in front of him was just an overactivation
of the visual centers of his brain, most likely
due to the strain from long hours of meditation.
Deciding to humor his imagination, he began
treating the tulpa like he would any brother
of the temple, speaking to it out loud and
showing it respect and inclusion.
It was like having his own imaginary friend.
Yet over time, the tulpa began to become more
than just an image.
It began to have a physical effect on objects
around him, a bucket kicked over, a chair
pulled back as a brother went to sit down.
The imaginary friend was now more like a mischievous
invisible prankster, but still, one that only
he could see.
The brothers began to grow weary of the tulpa,
and with it, grew weary of the foreigner that
had brought it into existence.
Meanwhile, Steve had become amazed at his
level of success.
He began to wonder if he could manifest other
thoughts into existence.
He began to think about his life, his career,
his level of success.
He began to think about how he could apply
himself to impart his will on reality.
How he wanted more.
He focused on this goal of meditation and
yet could not help but find frustration in
his efforts.
It didn’t help that the brothers of the
monastery now openly resented him.
Steve’s demeanor began to change and become
less optimistic and more obsessed with the
memory of the repetitive monotony of his old
life before coming to the monastery.
His tulpa too began to change, no longer fat
with joy, its appearance began to thin.
What was once an embodiment of laughter and
happiness began to morph into a darker, more
mischievous entity.
The pranks too became more dangerous.
The tulpa began leaving buckets of scalding
hot water above door frames for unsuspecting
monks to walk through.
It then began filling the sandals of monks
with snakes.
Thankfully for the brothers of the monastery,
the snakes weren’t poisonous.
Until suddenly, on one particular occasion,
they were.
A pair of Fea’s Vipers appeared in the sandals
of a brother of the monastery, venomous snakes
that could only be found hundreds of miles
away in the south of Tibet, in a region Steve
had never heard of and had never been to.
It was an impossibility for him to have given
birth to the manifestation of this act without
its requisite knowledge.
Did this mean the tulpa had gained some means
of self-actualization?
Could it contemplate its own sentience?
Seeking to learn more answers about the nature
of the tulpa, Steve studied the teachings
of the Buddha, and the quest for enlightenment.
About Nirvana and the end to the cycle of
death and rebirth.
In his mind, Steve began to intertwine those
ideas with the memory of the mundanity of
his previous life, and the feelings that lingered
in his stomach of it being unfulfilling and
empty.
How he had desperately wanted the daily cycle
of mundanity to end.
How he had wanted peace.
Little did he know in doing so he was creating
a manifestation with the express goal of ending
his life.
As Steve began to enter longer and deeper
sessions of meditation, the tulpa began to
grow more self-actualizing and independent
of his will.
It became harder to control, maleficent.
And one day, Steve realized he could no longer
picture the laughing buddha that had once
filled him with joy.
From that moment on, the tulpa’s face became
unrecognizable, and was no longer in a fixed
state but in constant movement, so that no
facial features could be visible.
It was that night the monks had caught the
tulpa holding a knife to Steve’s throat.
Channeling their meditative power of actualization,
they managed to collectively banish the tulpa
from the monastery.
But it was not for long.
The tulpa began to follow Steve wherever he
went, a physical embodiment of his wish to
end the repeating cycle of his life and bring
him peace.
Peace by means of the extinguishing of his
life.
The existence of SCP-1447-1 was first brought
to the attention of Foundation staff when
“Steve” arrived at Site 73 seeking sanctuary
from the tulpa he had been running from.
It is unclear to Foundation staff how the
software mogul came to know of the location
of site 73.
All that could be gained from questioning
him on the matter is that he received the
information from the monks at a lamasery in
Qinghai province, China.
Steve was given the designation SCP-1447-2
because of his relation to the entity, and
then placed in secure confinement at the facility.
Two days later, security personnel made contact
with the entity when it attacked the facility
in search of the tech mogul, resulting in
the death of two agents.
The attacks from SCP-1447 ceased when “Steve”
was evacuated via airlift to London, and then
later moved again to site 60.
In just three weeks after this change, the
tulpa had already caught up with “Steve”,
attacking the facility and becoming enraged
by the interference from security personnel,
slaughtering countless members of SCP staff
in its wake.
It is here at this facility that the members
of security personnel were first able to use
high-caliber firepower to push back the tulpa’s
advance into a makeshift concrete enclosure,
which would eventually come to be SCP-1447-1’s
current containment cell.
Dr. Rolfus, an SCP researcher, was the first
to interview Steve after assigning him the
designation SCP-1447-2.
He was given this designation when Foundation
staff realized that the person known as “Steve”,
(real name redacted), had in fact never left
the United States for Qinghai Province, and
had been leading his life as a successful
tech mogul without any notable interruption.
Researchers became unsure of whether “Steve”
was in fact who he said he was, or instead
an entity similar to SCP-1447-1.
When confronted with images of his doppelganger
in news and media reports living out his life
and assuming his identity, SCP-1447-2 was
unable to explain the anomaly and asserted
that he was the true original version of himself,
suggesting that a rival technology company,
or even his own for that matter, may have
hired a look-alike to take his place as head
of the business in his absence.
When the public counterpart of SCP-1447-2
recently found deceased, testing of the subject's
hair and tissue showed no anamalous characteristics
of any kind.
It is believed SCP-1447-1 may have been somehow
responsible for the mysterious death.
A prevailing theory regarding the existence
of SCP-1447-2’s counterpart posits that
Steve may have been in fact able to manifest
two tulpas into existence.
Steve may have suffered a traumatic mental
breakdown that perhaps, unbeknownst to him,
led to the creation of a secondary personality
that later manifested itself into existence
following his training in meditation and practice
in creating a tulpa.
It may have been this dual manifestation that
led to Steve’s loss of control of SCP-1447-1
in the first place.
SCP-1447-2 remains adamant that he has the
power to put an end to the tulpa’s existence
through the application of methods of concentration
and meditative practice.
SCP-1447-2 dedicates at the very least 4 hours
a day to meditating on the following topics;
“SCP-1447-1 is getting weaker, SCP-1447-1
is dying, SCP-1447-1 is unable to maintain
physical form.”
To his credit, Foundation researchers have
observed SCP-1447-1’s is severely curtailed
during periods in which its counterpart engages
in focused meditation on the abolition of
the tulpa.
During these periods SCP-1447-1 is almost
completely still, adopting the vajra meditation
position.
It is believed that through self-actualization,
the tulpa can meditate on its own existence,
counteracting the meditative “attacks”
against its ability to exist in its manifested
form.
To aid in this endeavor, Foundation staff
have considered different ways to disrupt
SCP-1447-1’s meditation.
At first, they suggested a hydrochloric acid
bath be pumped into its enclosure, but then
withdrew that proposal on fears it would surely
use whatever delivery mechanism into the enclosure
as a means of escape.
Further suggestions put forward for the matter
include using microwave emitters to remotely
heat the interior of the unit, and the use
of high-volume, high-intensity sonic equipment
proven to inhibit concentration.
Staff is also instructed to assist in this
effort by channeling positive thoughts incorporating
the demise and destruction of SCP-1447-1.
Positive slogans are posted in the hallways
and break rooms around the facility to assist
in positive thinking.
Weekly therapy visits for all staff members
are mandatory to ensure an environment of
strong mental health.
And complimentary gym memberships are given
out to employees to promote physical wellbeing
and motivated thinking.
In the only interview on file with the human
known as SCP-1447-2, “Steve”, Dr. Rolfus
asked the subject what would happen if the
tulpa were allowed to kill him.
SCP-1447-2 refused to answer, leaving Foundation
researchers to arrive at two possible theories.
First, if SCP-1447-1 destroys the human that
is responsible for its existence, then surely
it too will cease to exist.
Though when researchers tested this theory
by inflicting different levels of physical
pain to SCP-1447-2, the tulpa appeared to
have no effect or change in its behavior.
The second theory, and the one with the greater
support of evidence, is if the tulpa kills
SCP-1447-2, and it has already demonstrated
that it has the ability to meditate on its
own existence, then its behavior from then
on out is entirely impossible to predict.
At the moment, its fixation on SCP-1447-2
has been a large contributing factor to the
facility’s ability to contain it.
If it were to decide that its new purpose
was to bring its version of “peace” to
every life on the planet, there would be little
the Foundation could do to stop it.
That outcome must be avoided at all costs,
and by extension, the life of the human known
as SCP-1447-2 must be protected.
So hopefully, you’ve never had an imaginary
friend manifest itself into existence and
try to kill you.
But what we can all agree on is that some
things are better left in our forgotten childhood
memories.
Now go check out “SCP-5254 - Gotta Catch
'Em All” and “SCP-6080 - Cartoon Network”
for more childhood terrors made real!